[Music]
[Applause]
he's coach prime coach deon sanders
jackson state head coach and of course
hall of famer joining us on behalf of
gillette which we'll uh talk about here
in a moment sorry we don't have you in
the man cave but you're looking good how
would you sum up the last month for you
dion
it's been great first of all i got to
give you thanks my man you remember this
this kind of started on your show
i told you my plans on the show
well were we in miami where where was
that that was miami it was miami you
guaranteed that you would be coaching
head coach
but it started with you i mean it was it
was a reality i knew what i was getting
ready to do and i thank you for the
platform like you always provide me man
you're a great guy you know that you're
a great guy everybody loves you man i
appreciate it but when did you
realize or come up with the plan of how
do i make this bigger
i the program might not be bigger
recognition wise
but how can i make this bigger wherever
i go well dan that's who i am um coming
into the nfl you gotta understand that
defensive back was one of the lowest
paid positions but
we performed and made it bigger going
into uh
um just taking that position and going
from team to team city to city
everything
was bigger so this is no different from
once i played that's just who i am and
that's what i do and that's how i go
about my job and i just want to make
people uh more comfortable uh alarm
sound alarm and let people know what
hbcus have and that's what i'm pretty
good at
take me into the room or
come into my living room and sell me
i don't have to say i don't ain't
selling that
i'm that's the thing about it i don't i
don't sell anything i don't have
anything to sell i'm to pretty much
allow you to understand that i've sat on
three sides of the table
i'm in the living room like you i'm the
parent
and i've been the kid
now i'm the coach
that's a that's a has that's a heck of
an advantage because i know the thought
processes of everyone
provided in this room
so i'm i'm not selling anything but i'm
i'm gonna promise you that if you send
me a boy i'm gonna send you back a man
are you closing mom
are you closing the actual recruit
um it depends on
who
is the influencer influencer it depends
on see oftentimes not dead you gotta
understand man
sometimes it's the 707 coach sometimes
it's the high school coach sometimes
it's the dad sometimes it's the mom
sometimes it's the uncle you don't know
who it is
i focused on the heart and and i just
tell i'm honest man i'm just brutally
honest i'm not promising you no nils i'm
praying that you get to the nfl and i'm
just telling you what it is i'm gonna
give you an opportunity and i'm gonna
make sure you're when you lay your head
it's to be comfortable and you're going
to get three meals a day everything else
is on you
if you ran the ncaa what would you do
with name image and likeness
hbcus are at a tremendous disadvantage
because of the giving
because of the boosters because of the
uh
amount of
visual
and understanding so
i would alter the rules
it would be different rules for for dip
for fcs other than fbs is is it's not
equatable it don't even make sense
so we would be able to do a little more
a little more with our kids
would you put a cap on it
you can't cap it yeah i know
you can't you can't cap it
i mean uh this is the problem i have
like you have some guys that fbs's that
you hear
that man they're getting 800 or 900 a
million dollars dan what have you seen
them on
what what are they endorsing i ain't
seen it yet
but you have you know hbcu kids you have
someone like my son you seen him with
the brady line with beats uh uh
gatorade you you've seen the stuff this
tangibly you could see it
i hadn't seen any of the others the kid
that left ohio state
that said he was close to
how do you let somebody walk away with
close to a million dollars that you said
the kid from oklahoma that left and went
to south carolina how do you walk away
i don't understand that
and now you've got some of the big
schools depending on lime and every
limited signs get 50 grand we can't
compete with that man
we can't compete with that there's no
equality in it what would you have
gotten at florida state with name image
and likeness
uh
i probably had uh probably named imagine
like this on the stadium
[Laughter]
do you still are you able to run at all
when you go out to practice
you know when kids want to challenge you
well well then i went through some some
heck of a
things this season so
no not now
before i went through all my trials and
tribulations this season i'm barely
walking right now so
before yeah before yes i was i was being
able to show them not tell them what to
do but show them
how's your health now
i'm just getting better i'm walking you
know
i'm walking slowly
slowly
but it it's probably a cool walk that
you have it's just a slow walk i'm
getting there it's a beat now it's a
beat in my head when i'm walking
uh
i uh i was talking to troy aikman troy
was with us last hour and i said uh
better athlete
dionne or bo jackson
he said well i got to go dion he was my
teammate that's my guy let me ask you
better athlete you or bo jackson i
believe i'm a better athlete
bowl
physically
is a specimen that his strengths his
strength
is
you're going to see it when he walks up
to you and when he played the game
but
you talking about basketball fishing you
yeah i could do it
wait
heck of a hunter he could out hunt me
okay but you can out fish him
i gotta fish him all day long
you know i would actually watch that
just you and bo fishing and talking
because we were you think about it bo
and i
have sat down once in the locker room in
chicago when i was playing for the reds
i believe and i wasn't playing on that
sunday
and he came over to our locker room and
i was had off day
we sat and talked for hours man
i i wish america would have been able to
witness that and we want to do it again
we haven't really sat down and just
chopped it up
in the last 20 years or so
and i love him if it weren't for boy it
wouldn't have been no problem
how so
bo paved the way man he he uh
he he set the bar
it it has to be something that a man
chases and he set the bar for me to
chase something man and uh and i applaud
him for that
i never
mentally was against bo i've always said
dang that dude is unbelievable man
and i i i that challenged me to get to
that level
okay so who's setting the standard for
you as a coach what what are you chasing
who are you chasing
shoot
coach saban
coach saban is the bar coach saban is
the magna [ __ ] laude man coach saban and
his program and the way he runs this
program is
is all of that i admire it i love it
when we shot the app like spot shoot i
took a few of my coaches down to glean
from their coaches i know some of his
coaches on staff
we've watched him in off-season training
we we've simulated a lot of things he is
the gold standard and will always be
but you aspire to be in the sec or you
aspire to be in you know anything
to dominate where my feet are
i don't say i'm going to be in the sec
i'm going to be
wherever my feet are i'm going to be
dominant
why didn't florida state hire you to
begin with i have no idea there were
three others too so
[Laughter]
what who are the other schools that made
a mistake
they were they were firefighters
yeah
that was that yeah but what was the hold
up
excuse me what what was the hold up with
these schools and why why was there
hesitancy well willy wonka you know i
come from a chocolate factory man i
don't know
no
[Laughter]
i i didn't hear the commissioner
yesterday say anything about willy wonka
during his press conference there dionne
what would you suggest to the
commissioner about hiring practices in
the nfl with minorities i would go
different i i wouldn't
i'm not fighting for
the coaches i i i'm a guy that's an
advocate for ownership i would want to
expand into three more cities
i would say let's expand to three more
cities in three of those cities we have
to mandate um
african-american or ethnic ownership
then let it roll wherever it may be
but it has to be a mandate three cities
wherever those are
has to be
ethnic ethnic owned
i like that yeah
i like that is
let's go to the top and see where it
falls but you know dion it feels like
every year it's groundhog day and the
commissioner has his state of the union
and we keep talking about the hiring
practices and then next thing you know
we got a super bowl and then we move on
to the combine and then the draft and
then we forget about all of this stuff
you can't make no billionaire hired who
he
yes who he doesn't want to hurry that's
not gonna happen you can't make me hire
a cook or a housekeeper then i don't
wanna have in my house that's my house
yeah you're not gonna come here and tell
me what to do in my house it's not gonna
happen so let's just go to the top i'd
rather us own the house then we call the
shots in the house
uh the pro bowl i saw where you're
tweeting about how they the pro bowl
doesn't have an identity dion what uh
what could we do can we salvage the pro
bowl no because the players are
different the thought processes are
different so it's unsalted salvageable
you can't they don't want to play they
don't want to participate they don't
want to compete anything after the
season they do not want to compete and
there's afraid of the injury and aspect
as if we didn't think about that as well
but you know when you're a competitor
man you don't think about getting hurt
when i walk on the field i didn't think
about oh man i may get hurt
when i get in the car and think hey man
i may have accident no you have no
protection uh that was absurd what
transpired
in uh vegas it really was we gotta you
gotta go in a different direction that's
not right
um the fans don't deserve that the
players gotta really think about what
they're displaying on field i don't know
who was the guy that came up and said
guys we're just gonna play touch
that footage he should be fine
did you ever ask a quarterback to
autograph an interception ball
no
at practice i did in college
but practically
but you would never ask like
i would trade jersey to take off my
jersey and give it to another man after
the game either i would never do that
i would never i'm gonna fight and go
ahead against jerry rice and we gonna
stand there on the field after the game
i know that my error we
we weren't friendly like that we were
cool me and playmaker i love him to life
but we weren't doing it after the game i
i didn't want nothing to do with you no
no no
the game has changed everybody even in
the nba man everybody's friends now man
everybody's home boys everybody look up
to one another that you're playing
against i'm not looking up to the guy
i'm playing against i'm not i'm not
putting him on a pedestal i'm trying to
destroy him
uh what are you doing with gillette
so wonderful thanks man gillette uh
provide me options and i love it i got
to get this tagline now it gives a shave
and quick and easy as washing your face
and that's the god honest truth i'm a
shaver man if i don't if i go a day and
a half with that shave i'm fully great
i'm fully great
and gillette makes it so darn easy for
me they're doing some wonderful
activations at the super bowl uh
um nationwide check out uh santa monica
go to gillette.com
skate they're doing some wonderful
things man some wonderful giveaways and
i'm excited i mean i'm a gillette guy my
sons i've taught them how to shave at an
early age they're able to do
partnering with me in this campaign and
i love it i really do so if i go to
jackson state i don't get name image and
likeness i just get a razor no no no you
don't get named if you're good it's good
how do you have value coming out of high
school
how do what what is your value
you better you got to prove something
right i would think you have to prove
something man i i don't i don't get it i
i'm happy that these kids are are making
money and they're doing their thing but
you got to prove yourself that's that's
the world i lived in that's the world i
grew up in you got to prove yourself
first and i might have to come down
there and uh work out
you got to we're going to make sure
you're properly shaved would you let me
go
i can finally beat you in the 40.
you can't right now
i can beat you in the i don't care when
i beat you but if if i beat you that's
it
right now i think you can it's small
window and i like my chances here
oh i'm not together i don't have all my
digits
uh great to talk to you as always
congrats and uh thanks again
you're a classic man i love you and let
me tell you something i haven't
forgotten about those grills you bless
me so much those grills are unbelievable
man well i got chad from traeger out in
the parking lot
they're cooking up uh lunch today and
tomorrow with the traeger girls
i'm thankful for gillette and then my
relationship with them because i
actually shaved every day but
what you did for me with traeger
i'm serious every time i grill i think
about you every time
thank you dion
dion sanders jackson state head coach
and of course hall of famer joining us
on behalf of gillette